sir have you broken have you spoken to
your brother since the interview
yeah but i will do prince william is
speaking out
after prince harry and meghan markle's
shocking interview with oprah winfrey
is that the royal family a racist family
sir they were very much not the places
the 38 year old duke of cambridge broke
his silence on thursday when he and his
wife
kate middleton were visiting a london
school
while they were braced for for something
explosive they totally underestimated
just how far harry and megan would go
and i think they took everyone by
surprise
sir have you broke have you spoken to
your brother since the interview
i haven't told you yet but i will do and
and can you just let me know is that the
royal family a racist family sir
william's comments come after his
sister-in-law megan's claims in the
tell-all interview that there were
concerns about how dark her and terry's
son
archie's skin might be before he was
born
in those months when i was pregnant all
around the same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what there's a conversation
with you with harry when harry joined
the interview
he wouldn't reveal which member of the
royal family he had that conversation
with
but he later told oprah that it wasn't
his grandparents queen elizabeth ii
and prince philip the talk at the palace
is that they are
absolutely horrified by what has been
said they feel that
harry has literally thrown the family
under a bus
earlier this week buckingham palace
released a statement on behalf of the
queen
explaining that the family is saddened
to learn how challenging the last few
years have been for megan and harry
adding that the issues raised
particularly that of race
are concerning the queen was very
concerned about the whole situation
the palace's statement concludes while
some recollections may vary
they are taken very seriously and will
be addressed by the family privately
harry megan and archie will always be
much-loved family members
william is is devastated by this
interview don't forget the duchess of
cambridge has been dragged into this
whole saga and william will will hate
that
um and of course relationship between
father and son
is now at an all-time low